I'm feeling very Icelandic. I'm looking at ice,  there's a landline in my room, and I'm not opposed to dick.
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know, now you know, and your life is different now!
I've seen a lot of people doing these very honest Q and A's here on YouTube
So I thought, why not? I've been on the internet for it now seven--eight years. Something like that
So why not start telling you the truth about me?
I'm sure a lot of what you might hear in these answers are things that I've said other videos or in my books or on the podcast
Or whatever, but hey...
Let's talk about the weird awkward stuff in an awkward Q&A. I went on Twitter and asked you guys for questions using the hashtag
AwkwardlyAskGrace, and do you all work for UPS? Because you guys really delivered. Let's just do this, okay?
Let's just jump right in. "When did you lose your virginity?"
This is a real easy question to start off with. I wrote about this in my book if you didn't read it already,
and I've talked about it numerous times in videos,
but for those of you that do not know: I lost my virginity when I was 18 years old,
I was a freshman in college. A guy that
I was sort of dating on my indoor track team asked me on a date for Valentine's Day. And I was so excited
I'd never been on like an official date before.
So went to Macy's and I got myself the most Avril Lavigne looking skirt, with even like a little chain on it
She was really cute at that time. Maybe
She wasn't cute at that time, but I just -- I liked her aesthetic and thought she was cool
And she and I share the same birthday. And then he took me to a Macaroni Grill
Which if you're not familiar is a chain Italian restaurant in which they give you crayons, and you can
*Slow-motion voice*: Draw on the tabletop
And I thought, "Oh my God,
This is the fanciest meal I've ever had in my life.
Let's do this." And by "this" I mean sex. And it was not good *laughs* but we dated for two years, so *laughs*
Oh the places you can go when you give a girl in an Avril Lavigne skirt and the opportunity to draw on the
Tablecloth *laughs*
"Weidest thing you've done in public". There's a couple things. Before I starting making Youtube videos,
I was doing a lot of odd jobs and a lot of shoots. One of my first, like, paid acting gigs was for TruTV
I worked as an assistant to a
process server. A process server is someone that serves people legal papers, like divorce papers or um
papers warnings of suings and things like that.
So there was this, like, pseudo reality television show on truTV about this process
server named Byron. And it had been going on for seasons, and Byron was a real life process server in real life.
So they brought me in as this new storyline as his like dip-sh*t, airhead assistant
that was just like *airhead-y sound* girly and like totally incapable. And they would set up scenarios all around
Manhattan and New Jersey and then we'd just have to improvise out these scenarios,
and they always turned into like crazy elaborate physical things. One was in a
salon in Harlem, where we had to serve the salon owner papers,
and he ended up getting burned on a curling iron and throwing, like, talcum powder everywhere.
Salon Owner: Get in your car! *Byron protests and Grace shouts* You want it too, bitch? You want it, too?
There was one with a pizza shop in New Jersey,
and they ended up throwing pizza dough in my hair and pouring lasagna on our car.
Byron: I can't believe you--
Grace: What is that?
Both: Oh my God!
One was, we had to serve this, like, high-profile hedge fund dude while was jogging in Central Park.
And I had to jog along with him, and then Byron and him got into an altercation, and the security guards came out of nowhere, and, like,
lifted me up and carried me away.
Grace: Don't touch him. Don't. Touch. Him!
Byron: You've been served.
You would have to do these stunts in public and let them play out for like
15-20 minutes while the public watched
And then we'd have to do them again, and sometimes a third time, and it was some of the most embarrassing stuff
I did
But you know, I was really dedicated to the art of improvisation and acting and I really wanted to make it big *laughs*
"What's the worst part about being a YouTuber?" Obviously, there's a billion tremendous things about being a YouTuber.
But one of the worst parts about being a YouTuber, or just being in the creative world in general, is
comparing yourself to other people. I struggle with that a lot.
I sometimes get into really negative head spaces because it's so easy to comparing numbers and to compare statistics and to wonder why
you aren't doing as well as other people, and that is a very very terrible, isolating and
discouraging thought process, that I have to learn to shake for myself, because it gets you nowhere.
It just waste your time, so instead, focus on the things you can control and can do. That's not me saying that to you.
It's more me saying that to myself, so...
You're -- you're just...
here for that. Thanks, I guess. *laughs*
"Awkwardest teenage moment-story?"
I think I've told this story before, too, but I'll tell it again.
When I was in high school
I worked at Chili's, my favorite restaurant, so I'd already peaked in my career endeavors at that point.
I was a hostess,
and I had a crush on one of the busboys and afterward they used to go to this billiards or like pool
bar where they would smoke and play pool, and so my friends and I went with them one night
And I lied to my mom and said
I was sleeping at my friend's house
And really I was trying to stay out and hang out with these busboys from the restaurant.
I did actually end up sleeping at my friend's house, but they all went home,
and I tried to stay later. And, like, nothing was going to happen with this boy, and nothing did happen. So, I walked to my car
to leave, and as I was leaving the parking lot there was a
light and this car had been stopped at the light, and I was trying to pull up next to the car so I could make a left-hand turn.
And when I pulled up next to the car -- I have no spatial awareness, I'm the worst driver.
Wasn't drinking it all this night.
My car, which I called "The Ox", at the time --
a '97 Dodge Intrepid
-- these are not important details, but it paints a picture.
The side view window on the right passenger side knocked
into this car's side view window, and knocked it off. Immediately,
I didn't know what to do, and the car got right behind me, and it was this total South Jersey bro-
dude, tatted up, with two very...
minimally clothed women in the car.  And the guy thought I was a guy, and so he just starts
raging out, he starts screaming at me:
*in deep voice* "You knocked my f*cking window off! You knocked my f*cking window off! I'm gonna go beat the sh*t outta you!"
He gets out of his car, the girls are like: *unintelligible squeaky noises*,
screaming at this guy. I don't know what to do. The light's still red. It hasn't changed, so I can't drive away.
He gets up to my window as if he's going to rip me out of the car, he gets in,
and then they sees that I'm, ike, a little, scared child.
I think I was 16 or 17 years old, and a little scared girl
staring back at him, like, tears in her eyes, and he's like, *in deep voice again* "Oh,
yo, I -- I'm sorry. I thought -- I thought you were a dude --
I'm so sorry. I can pop this back into place, don't worry,
I'll just -- I'll pop it back into place."
And he just literally popped his window back into place, got in his car, and drove away. It all happened
so quick, I was so terrified, and when he had driven away, I finally looked down,
and I had pissed my pants *laughs*
Which answers a lot of your questions that you guys tweeted at me about when the last time was I full-on pissed my pants, and
I think that was it. Oh...
How many mems are coming up in this
Awkward
Q&A? "Do you enjoy compliments or do they make you uncomfortable?" Compliments make me uncomfortable, but I'm learning to take them
better... "What should you do when you're suddenly stuck by your period while in public?"
Ooh...get thee to a toilet! And make thee a
tampon out of toilet paper until you can get yourself a real tampon or a pad or whatever you need to do.
That's my piece of advice. That's a fun, ya know, little mental game for yourself if you're really bored in a place.
Just look around and think:
What could be a tampon? "What is the worst thing about dating?"
Ooh
I think the worst thing about dating is
finding someone that you're very attracted to, that kind of checks off all the boxes of a person that you wanna... investigate more as a
potential...
situation. And then finding out that they're unavailable. That is sooo
heart gutting! It gets all the guts out of your heart! "Are you doing another film this year?" Hopefully, yes.
And hopefully more than one.
That's all I'll say about that. "Would you ever make a video of you trying to see if food life hacks really work or not?"
Yeah,
definitely.
If that's something you guys want to see let me know. Leave a comment down below. Should I do a food hack
video? Should I jump on that bandwagon?
I'm really good at jumping. I did triple jump when I was in high school. Track and field.
"What's your favorite movie-slash-TV project you've done so far?" We've done so many
awesome projects. One of my most favorites that, unfortunately,  didn't get as much
promotion as I was hoping it would get, was Electra Woman and Dyna Girl, that Hannah Hart and I did.
I believe it's still on Full Screen. I think you can still watch it on iTunes.
I loved that project so so much. It was such a joy to film, and so I -- if you guys haven't checked it out,
please do. "YouTube crush." I have a group crush. I have a big boner for that friend group
that is Scotty and Toddy and Zane and Heath and Liza and David and those kids.
I think that they're really fun, and I just wish they would ask me to hang out and get drunk with them.
Was that so desperate sounding? "What was your most awkward dream?"
Ooh recently I dreamt twice, two seperate dreams in one night, that I was just chewing glass.
And it was getting stuck in my teeth,
and I couldn't get out of my teeth. Like corn, but sharp, painful corn. "When you see an ex boyfriend
do you ever think, 'Wow. Meth would have been a
smarter bad decision.'?"
No.
I think all my ex-boyfriends have been in my life for a...very important reason. As, maybe, cheesy as that sounds.
But, I like to look back fondly on the relationships
I've had and
really try to process what I gained from them,
and how I've grown since them, and what I've learned.  God, I'm old, because that sounds really healthy.
"What's the weirdest thing you've woken up to after a particularly drunk night?" I've woken up to my keys in my refrigerator. *laughs*
I've woken up to so many different food combinations. Many different clothes, mine, strewn everywhere.
Onesies that I decided to try on by myself
I guess. Lots of fun little treasures. "Are you getting bored or frustrated with YouTube?" Sometimes
I am. It's only normal that you would get bored or frustrated or burntout or worn out by a thing you're doing,
especially after seven or eight years of doing it.
I think I'm in a little bit of a valley and I'm trying to get up to a peak. How do I get up to
a peak, you guys? I really gotta work on some f*cking clickbait thumbnails and titles, goddammit.
"Uhhh did ever bring anything awkward to show and tell at school?"
In kindergarten. I brought my pussy.
My family had just got a kitten, named Taker,
and I brought it to show and tell. Okay! That's it for this awkward
Q&A. I hope this was fun for you guys. If you like this kind of video,
let me know, because this is...I don't know, kind of
therapeutic and kind of fun to make, so maybe I'll make more. Give this video a thumbs up if you like it
and if you want more awkward Q&A's, from me, your awkward older sister, Grace Anne Helbig, The First.
Oh, don't forget to subscribe to this YouTube channel, because that's how I know that people want to see things.
I make videos Monday, Wednesday, and Friday. Sometimes. Other than that, I don't know...
"Similar to what you ask in Not Too Deep, describe your worst sexual experience in three words or phrases." Did you fart? *laughs*